when you're winning you're not as good
as you think you are when you're losing
you're not as bad as you think you are
what's that mean to you both of them lie
when you're winning everybody's telling
you how amazing you are you're the best
you're amazing it always takes me back
to that quote of Marcus aelius who had a
slave that would sit behind him and
always whisper to him you're just a man
you're just a man you're just a man and
then he would get up and he became the
best Emperor we read about him now you
pick up the book meditations you're like
this is mandatory reading for anybody
what is this all about simple book not
that big and you're going through it
saying what was this about then you
Google what did he mean by this wow I
didn't think about it that way and then
when you're losing everybody tells you I
told you shouldn't have done that I knew
you wern't going to make it and you
believe that as well